this video is brought to you by privacy
calm which lets you buy things online
using virtual cards protecting your
identity and bank information on the
Internet in this video we're gonna be
going over a couple of reasons why you
absolutely should not buy the new Galaxy
Notes hen that Samsung just revealed at
their unpacked event now there's also
the note 10 + which looks to be a much
better phone but as we'll talk about in
just a minute you should probably think
twice about buying that model as well we
just finished the note 10 event and we
noticed that Samsung talked a lot about
features that are already available on
their s10 line of phones for example the
s10 already has the same exact dynamic
AMOLED display except that it's actually
1440p instead of only 1080p on the note
10 which is a shocker on top of that the
s10 already has the ultrasonic
fingerprint sensor that they showed off
at the event it also seems to have the
same exact cameras as the no 10 samsung
didn't mention any camera differences at
all except for the live focus video
feature which seems to only be coming on
the note 10 plus since it has a 3d depth
sensor the note 10 actually still has
the same exact processor as the s10 now
their spec sheet shows that the note 10
has the SM 81 57 nanometer processor but
that's actually the code name for the
snapdragon 855 that's already in the S
10 so there's no difference there
they mentioned support for fast wireless
charging 2.0 and yep the SN has that as
well and basically everything else they
showed off was either already available
on the s10 or a software feature like
Samsung decks which is yet again
available on the S 10 they did mention
continuity between the note 10 and
Windows computers which i think is
really cool but that's also coming on
the S 10 as well I'd say the biggest
difference is the S Pen which has gotten
some pretty impressive updates but to be
completely honest we still think it's a
gimmick for most people I'll let max
explain why hey guys
I've owned three different notes two of
which I actually use as my main devices
long term and I think my experience with
a matchup with a lot of other people I
know as well as other reviewers whenever
I got a new know I played around the S
Pen for a few days to a week tried out
the new features and generally thought
it was really cool but after that I
ended up rarely using it and long term I
didn't use it at all if you phone to
know let me know your experience with
the s-pen and how often you used it down
in the comments below I'd love to hear
you guys as opinions for the most part I
think people bought the note devices
because they wanted a bigger screen but
recently Samsung has made their S series
of phones have big screens as well with
the S 10 plus having a screen even
bigger than the standard Note 10 so for
most people that's no longer a selling
point all right back to you team so when
you take a look at everything you get
the new note 10 compared to the S 10 it
doesn't really seem worth it the S 10
has a higher resolution display it
actually comes with a headphone jack
which is scrapped on the NOAA 10 and the
SN comes with a micro SD card slot which
according to mkbhd is gone on the note
10 so all in all you really don't get
much of anything new or very impressive
on the note 10 and seeing as the SN has
been around for a couple of months
already
you can now find it for as low as six
hundred dollars refurbished on Amazon
with a warranty in the US or if you're
fine with buying used you can find one
on Craigslist for even less than that
and those prices should be going down
even more with the release on the new
note phones so for those reasons we
recommend that you do not buy a Galaxy
Note 10 and go buy a Galaxy S 10 for
much less cash and enjoy the better
display headphone jack and micro SD card
slot now let's talk about the note 10
plus which is the star of the show
you've got a larger 6.8 inch screen with
1440p resolution a larger battery the 3d
depth camera for scanning objects and
using live focus video mode you get up
to 512 gigabytes of storage with a micro
SD card slot and finally you get 45 watt
super fast charging if you buy the
bricks separately and even with all that
the note 10 plus still feels a bit
mediocre the S 10 plus has the same
great display albeit not as large you
can actually get one terabyte of storage
on the SN Plus with the ceramic model
which also comes with 12 gigabytes of
RAM just like the note 10 plus the
processors are yet again exactly the
same and the cameras are basically the
same except for lacking the 3d depth
camera and if you really want that you
can get the S 10 5g which comes with the
3d camera 5g networking and even larger
battery than the note 10 plus what I'm
trying to say is that there really
that much new and special about even the
plus-size model of course it's gonna be
a great phone and a lot of people are
gonna buy it but it starts at $1,100 and
it's not that much better than s10 plus
which you can find for much cheaper
online or find used for even less now
here's something else to think about
Apple's iPhone event is next month and
they're coming out with new iPhones
which will pack the upcoming a13
processor and seeing as the current 812
processors are already on part with the
snapdragon 855 and the note 10 plus we
should be seeing a massive boost in
performance and we're actually planning
on buying the note 10 plus just so we
can compare it to the iPhone 10s Macs
and upcoming iPhone 11 so if you're not
already subscribed make sure to do so
right now so basically you've got a
couple of options you can buy the note
10 or note 10 plus which really aren't
that impressive or you can save some
cash and go with one of the galaxy s 10
line of phones or you can wait a month
for Apple's iPhone 11 in a time where
credit card data breaches seems to be
the new norm
privacy comm makes it extremely easy to
use virtual cards to protect your
identity and bank information completely
free sign up at privacy calm slash max
tech and you can quickly create virtual
card numbers that are locked to whatever
merchant you shop at so even if it's
hacked they won't be able to use them
elsewhere you can even make one-time use
cards which are great for single
payments trials that require cards and
for sketchy sites and you can set a
variety of limits so you'll never be
built twice or upgraded to another
service there chrome extension makes it
easy to use by Auto filling your card
info and unlike credit card companies
privacy does not sell your data but
keeps it safe using military-grade
encryption and is held to the same
standards as banks not only is it
completely free but if you sign up today
they'll give you five bucks to spend
anywhere so visit privacy comp such max
tech or use the link below to start
keeping your banking info safe let us
know your thoughts down in the comments
below and make sure to tap that like
button and check out those two videos
right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]